I mean people don't realize some Dame
killing is the hardest I've ever seen
anybody kill at that time you know what
I'm gonna say this and this is gonna
cause controversy it was either him or
Mencia [ __ ] kill dude that like back
in the day yeah Carlos Mencia was
unfavorable you could argue against it
that's fine I will argue against it the
problem with Carlos is that you didn't
want to do your good [ __ ] around him so
it's like you ended up doing like crowd
work or something and the energy would
just dump yeah I mean dude I used to
fall Carlos all the [ __ ] time and
yeah people just don't wanna get yelled
at you know here's the thing about
Carlos and I've talked about some other
things I know he's doing like a tour of
apology ain't that mean want to come on
my podcast I'd love to have a [ __ ]
talk with him because he followed me
he's a fought like dude the guy would
call in and be like what's the line my
way he would let go can he do something
to you in Dallas yeah what okay well
tell that so I like I like you know I
humbly relationship with the improv
sometimes they love me sometimes they
don't and I was getting I I was doing
Addison right and we were having great
weeks ma'am so um I'm sitting there and
I'm just hanging out in the green room
which was the office back there and all
the side Williams waddle in like a major
walks in right
normal they don't wanna
it's Brad Williams I go oh [ __ ] that's
when you knew that Carlos was yeah yeah
yeah he's kind of like the court jester
okay walks at the time and I'm like Oh
Brad's here [ __ ] I love Brad it's not
his fault he's just you know trying to
get cribbage he'll probably will be like
yeah I'm sure I love I love Brad he's a
great become a great comic so anyways
Carlos comes in with this [ __ ] cartel
of Mexicans like just like ten Mexicans
with him right yeah and he's literally
like shaking everybody's hands in the
room but he shakes my hand he doesn't
make eye contact with me and he's like
oh hey hey this and I'm like this
[ __ ] because he used to call in
and find out where lineups are like
where the lamp is at the comedy store he
would always go right before me so that
I would cancel so then he'd start going
to in front of me so I couldn't say I do
my blonde after him he did all the
[ __ ] time
besides in Dallas now he's in Dallas
student I had this room would cut I had
this rule with Carlos that if he did
over 30 minutes I wasn't going up cuz
that to me is a headliner spot people
are like okay we saw the headliner let's
go the [ __ ] home yeah I tell him I go if
he does over 30 I'm [ __ ] going right
yeah they go that's totally cool he does
28 minutes no okay let me just say that
listening right so you're headlining yes
you're on the Billboard I am the
headlight The Improv yes he comes in yes
and he said what what what he didn't ask
okay okay but what does a manager say
it's like I know you're headlining but
Mencia is gonna go up I know how does
that woman see you once because what
happened was this was just after the Joe
Rogan snuff film came out ah you know
and uh he wasn't selling tickets in
theatres so he was trying to go around
to muster up people to come see him in a
theater ah and so he didn't even ask
he's like yeah he wants to guest spot
and I'm like I dude I would ask no no
you but can't you go No
I don't have that kind of power you can
you do I mean I did I well I didn't feel
at the time I mean you know hey should
we play I would be like no I'm had money
I know he's a big star or whatever at
the time but I'll be like no I mean
that's just not right you know it's just
they're so wrong and right and and you
know I know it's about the bottom dollar
but it's like but I don't think he sells
any at that I listen I get for the club
at the time it means like people go oh
dude girls Mencia popped in at the time
you know that meant something oh nothing
you know so anyways he goes up there and
if you listen to him on the Marc Maron
podcast he talks about how he'd like to
teach people lessons he was the alpha
dog he wanted to dominance well that's
what he's trying to do but dog I'm oh
I'm all Oh ROG dog I had to foul
everybody a thousand [ __ ] times so
I'm not like there's I mean sometimes
like why I got five but you just go into
fight mode what upset me dude
so he does his act and he's going for
blood like he's going to bury me and I
remember him getting done and the place
goes nuts right and then he goes are you
guys ready for your headliner and
literally the entire room goes oh I hear
oh-ho someone's got a father they're all
thinking someone's got a [ __ ] father
and then I swear to God for the first
time in my life I got tunnel vision and
I was like oh [ __ ] that person's me oh
my god so so he does the thing that is
unforgivable at this moment he
introduces me and runs off stage doesn't
even wait to shake my hand say thanks
for putting me up runs like and that's
how I knew he was trying to teach me cuz
I'm coming this way he runs this way he
runs off stage I have to go up on stage
I have this joke I do that does really
well when you follow murderer and I drop
it and the place explodes and I crush
for an hour yeah people still come up to
me that we're there at the club I'm
amazed and they're like dude I room and
I got off stage and so I go to the
I crushed I couldn't believe I'm like
well I'm [ __ ] crush yeah so I go to
the next door is this awesome piano yeah
you go in and do the whole clearly the
entire bar goes you follow them like nut
or lines a movie the whole place like
you did yeah yeah well I forgot we had
another show and everybody's buying me
drinks bro
and by the time the next show comes up I
am blackout drunk and I do my entire set
leaning against the football I was crazy
though back I used to do dry humping
contests right like what is it you
should try to get girls pregnant on stay
it won't raise II yeah yeah you know
like different Tripoli now
[Music]